hello dear friends film lowers and
critics my name is julia timoshanko and
i'm the editor-in-chief of ukrainian
english and today we're going to look in
ukraine and the russian cinema
[Music]
we all know that collective societal
values beliefs and views of the world
are heavily influenced by the pop
culture as with any form of art films
can be used to defy critique or
reinforce cultural norms and political
ideologies analyzing films within their
political historic and geographic
context can really tell a lot about the
society where they emerged not only do
they tell a lot about their creators
such as directors screenwriters and so
on but they also give us a look into the
audience for whom they were created
today we're going to investigate the
role of filming the relationship between
ukraine and russia specifically in this
video we will focus on how ukrainians
have been portrayed in russian cinema
throughout history in this analysis put
together by vitaly gardienko
hi that's me i'm famous ukrainian
blogger by the way we will demonstrate
you that apart from promoting russian
colonial narratives russian cinema has
always been discriminating mocking and
belittling ukraine its culture language
and people not only the russian cinema
has fostered hatred among the russian
population towards ukrainians but it
also fostered an inferiority complex
among ukrainian population who consumed
a lot of russian content before 2014.
they often portray ukrainians as
cowardly and uneducated it's been
persuading ukrainians that there is
nothing cool about their nationality and
in order to appear
better they need to be more russian in
this video we will first look into some
examples of the films that came out
before 2014 the first russian invasion
of ukraine
yeah okay okay
[Music]
back then the relationship between these
two countries have been describing as
fun and friendly but then the narrative
strikingly shifts after 2014 invasion of
crimea and dunbas
the ukrainians are not anymore portrayed
as fun or friendly they're turned into
evilly traitors during the soviet times
ukrainians and films were portrayed as
funny cheerful but slightly backwards or
as russian like to call them poholz
hohol is a derogatory and discriminative
term used by russians to describe a
ukrainian person
in soviet cinema ukrainians were usually
represented by cheerful funny and quiet
simple mostly secondary characters if
you were even shown as army officers
others were representatives of lower
class society or peasants and after the
collapse of the soviet union this image
shifted and ukrainians became not
cheerful in panicho halls anymore but in
fact evil collaborators and traders
let's look into some examples in
chronological order brother the 1997
and 2000 film we'll start with a very
famous sequel in the russian modern
cinema to be honest these two films were
also very popular here in ukraine
these two films were directed by alexey
balabano and became an epitome of the
idea of the mysterious russian soul a
common trope that we can see in russian
literature and cinema today at the core
of the story we have a humble good guy a
little man who is capable of doing
everything for his own values and
beliefs although the first film is not
connected to ukraine at all it shows how
rooted discriminatory xenophobic and
racist views are in russian society the
dialogues are saturated with disrespect
for everything and everyone that is not
russian here are a few examples
of
we could assume that it's a deliberate
irony chosen by the director in order to
highlight problems in his native society
but do the viewers really understand
that
in the second part the director will
show that the hatred is not only
exclusive and inherent in russian
society the whole world is in fact built
upon that hatred according to this film
just think about what it says about the
whole world view of a common russian
person
the second film is more interesting when
it comes to the russian wars in the very
beginning we see the interview of the
main character on the television he is a
participant in the russian war against
chechnya the russian military potential
is glorified and being the soldier is
shown as cool we can immediately draw a
parallel to the war in ukraine
as we can see russian tactic of denying
the truth has not changed since the 90s
later in the story we were introduced to
ukrainians
and immediately after that we realized
that we're not going to be portrayed in
a very good context let us just watch
how the film decides to portray
ukrainians
and of course the ukrainians are the bad
guys and mostly referred to by an ethnic
slur
we hear how ukrainians in this film
refer to the russians as mosques
this was an ethnic name of the russians
before they adopted the name of kievan
roos
stole it and renamed the grain duchy of
moscow into russia russians actually
find this term offensive because it
really separates them from the history
of kievan ruse and
really undermines their entire historic
russian ideology
is actually filled with a lot of hatred
and fear in the russian society it
originated back from the name of stephan
bandera a leader of ukrainian
independence movement in the 40s
and now it's being used pretty much
against every ukrainian who believes in
the territorial integrity of their
country
later in the film they also promoted
propaganda about crimea remember this
was back in 2000. 2000
here you can see how russians are being
told they have lost crimea and they need
to take it back because it's
historically theirs
another very common and popular idea is
demonstrated here through a phrase
russians do not leave russians in the
war
this form of patriotism could actually
be inspiring if it was real the
russo-ukrainian war has proven that
russian leaders and military commanders
actually do not care about preserving
the lives of their personnel they didn't
care to save them from the mosque ship
and they also threw them on the front
lines without proper gear as cannon
nice plus the posterior
mass award and for the finale of the
film let's look at the legendary scene
about strength i will not comment on it
simply just view it through the lengths
of russian ukrainian war currently just
listen to this monologue
let's move to another film the nines
company it is the embodiment of how the
russian propaganda machine for years
demonstrated the strength and power of
the russian military it was telling how
prestigious it is to be a cadet soldiers
or go fight in afghanistan or kill
taliban in this way they raised a whole
generation obsessing with war oddly
enough these films did not prepare
russian soldiers for the brutal reality
of that war
[Music]
so what do they say about ukraine and
the ninth company well first of all
there was a ukrainian character who only
appeared for a while to talk about
ukraine and to fly the georgian
city
[Music]
foreign
but there is also another ukrainian
character will you guess his name
of course
let's move on to the next film called if
the military campaign is tomorrow this
film is actually about children's
relations the story takes place in
ukrainian crimea in 2004 and here is a
scene about two boys meeting for the
first time
first of all we hear a terrible
ukrainian spoken by the kid actor and
the next scene is actually mind-boggling
ukraine
a hint that even children know and
should know that crimea is a part of
russia the targeted audience for these
series are predominantly children
however it has very strong political
messages the ukrainian characters here
are the enemies so the boys begin to
fight
[Music]
and of course the russian beats the
ukrainian even though he is smaller in
one of the next scenes we see how
ukrainian crimean tatars are playing
nazi soldiers as if it is something
normal
the obsession with world war ii is
actually very common in russia they take
a lot of pride in the fact that they
beat nazis in the 40s and they failed to
recognize they're actually the nazis of
today of the 21st century here's another
russian claim for crimea
[Music]
is it now becoming more clear to you why
most russians are so okay with the
illegal annexation and occupation of
crimea the next film is called 72 meters
this is a russian war drama released in
2004 about navy crew that first served
in sevastopol during the times of the
soviet union after the 1991 the crew was
transferred to the northern fleet of the
russian federation unlike the other
films this one doesn't really deal much
with ukraine to be more precise not so
often ukraine was mentioned only in one
episode and once seen several characters
stay on the flooded ship and discuss
their past suddenly the character played
by marad basharo asked this question for
literally no reason
[Music]
and this dialogue prepares us for the
following scene which is meant to show
the extreme loyalty of the fleet of the
russian federation it shows how soldiers
did not take an oath to ukraine in 1991.
this obviously questions the entire idea
of the loyalty of ukrainians to ukraine
because they choose
to stay with russia
foreign
destroyer
[Music]
be
[Music]
the 2009 film this is a painful wound in
the history of ukrainian cinema an
authentic ukrainian story about the
cossacks was filmed by russians who in
the 18th century actually exterminated
those kha'zix moreover all of these
kozaks speak russian language which is
just historically wrong as most of them
spoke ukrainian in the main role we have
perhaps the symbol of the ukrainian
cinema bhutan stupka he praises the
russian soul from the first minutes of
the film
we don't really understand why stupka
decided to act in this film there is a
story behind us that somehow he was
presented with a different script at the
beginning and when he signed the
contract later those russian ideas were
added to the film most likely he would
have to pay a fine for breaching the
contract that's why he wasn't able to
quit terez bulba is an ideal work for a
russian film adaptation in his times
mccollough goggle the author of the
original novel pursuing pro-russian
political goals and fulfilling the
request of the government contrasts the
kha'zix with the polls and not the
russians with whom kozaks actually
fought at least as often as with the
polls showing how the kazakhs were
fighting against the polls and not the
moscow oppression helped to reinforce
the ideology of russian imperialism the
cossacks were basically painted into
russian soldiers which is again from
historical standpoint of view is
completely ridiculous
any eastern european historian would
actually find this bizarre because the
last thing the kha'zix did was praising
the great russia also in the film
ukraine is often pronounced as ocrana
which translates to borderland and makes
you think that it's not really a real
country by itself
the actors also twisted ukrainian
language making it sound kind of russian
there's also a scene where kha'zix get
drunk and miss the attack which is also
kind of ridiculous because kozaks
usually didn't drink during military
action
overall taras bulba is a gross twisted
misrepresentation of ukrainian and
quasar culture as they do it very often
russians just decided to appropriate
that piece of history and make it sound
and look russian the 2010 film kandahar
this film tells about a team of pilots
who were captured in afghanistan because
they were transporting ammunition one of
the pilots is ukrainian played by
another popular ukrainian actor bohudan
banuk the film was directed by andrei
cavun who is from aviv but he shot most
of his big projects in russia after 2014
he returned to ukraine to work in his
home country which is why it's pretty
surprising that his film kandahar
perfectly matches all the narratives of
russian propaganda the viewers
understand that this very character is
ukrainian actually by judging how he
talks in the middle of the russian
sentence he would insert ukrainian words
just randomly
here we see the usual archetype a stout
man with a moustache a typical peasant
during the whole movie he will only be a
tacit cowardly inferior ukrainian here
in the beginning he is scared and asks
to land while the russians proudly don't
want to give up
[Music]
further he continues to show his small
russian attitude
and further he appears as a dumb coward
later in the film he's only causing more
trouble
and again we see the continuation of the
narratives that the ukrainians are
cowards unable of any military gains or
progress unlike the russians
to sum it up banuk's character is dumb
ridiculous and covertly but he is still
loved by the audience because russians
and ukrainians are shown as the same
people apart from demonstrating the
evilness of the ukrainian people they
also like to steal our heroes in order
to show that there are actually no
ukrainians as such they're only little
russians as russians call us themselves
one example of such a tactic is a film
about ukrainian wrestler evan paduny who
was born to ukrainian family of cossacks
during the russian empire here the
history was also twisted to make
ukrainian potawa look like a typical
russian province where everyone behaved
like a russian
where children are running around in a
russian traditional clothing called
kosovo
and their fathers beat them if they do
not fight with other boys and cry like
girls ivanka dubney is also shown to act
like a stupid proud russian
[Applause]
he's capable of nothing except showing
off his physical strengths you may see
it in many scenes and it manifests
itself in a bunch of other episodes
in additions here russians are also
trying to appropriate kazakh history
because ivan por dubney is a descendant
of ukrainian kha'zix from zappos
and of course the film would not be
complete without devaluing the vest and
emphasizing the beauty of the isolated
russian world
but still one of the most interesting
facts about this film is that the
directors are intentionally trying to
cut out bibli from ukraine by showing
him as a completely russian man and not
showing ukraine in the film at all
the director actually decides to invent
a whole new nickname for evan p dubney a
russian bear that nickname cannot be
traced in any historic documents but
they really put it in our faces
throughout the film
but it turns out that the russians were
actually not convinced that pidubni was
their hero in 1988 they smeared his
grave and wrote
hole and bastard meaning that they still
know that he was actually ukrainian this
was only a selection of the prominent
russian films that came out before 2014.
as you can imagine there is so much more
there but we cannot fit it in one video
the ideas about ukrainians are pretty
much the same in most of them in case
you don't remember in 2014 russia
illegally occupied crimea and invaded
the eastern part of ukraine causing a
massive idp crisis destruction of the
infrastructure and economic downfall the
ukrainian government has responded to
the russian aggression by banning major
social media networks from russia and
screening the russian films in the
theaters however many ukrainians still
continue to consume russian content on
youtube music streaming platforms and so
on starting from 2014 russian cinema has
shifted its narrative completely in
regards to ukrainian ukrainians if until
then ukrainians were portrayed in their
films as antagonists after 2013 they
started completely disappearing from the
film screens how is it possible well the
russians started filming the films about
ukraine but without the ukrainians let
me show you the example of the battle
for sevastopol it's a biographical war
film about ludmila pavlichenko a young
soviet woman who joined the red army to
fight the german invasion of the ussr
and became one of the deadliest sniper
in the world war ii she actually took
down more than 300 enemy soldiers
despite that the film was a ukrainian
russian production the film does not
mention anywhere that the protagonist is
actually ukrainian ludmila was born and
raised near kiev and also that's where
she learned how to shoot well you can
say that it's implied because kiev is
mentioned in the movie quite a few times
however you never hear that the
ukrainians are fighting in the red army
in fact it's only russia that is
fighting against fascism according to
the film
the next film is called goggle the
beginning it is a 2017 russian fantasy
horror film director by igor barabov and
very very loosely based on the works of
a ukrainian writer michaela goggle
geographically the film set is in
ukraine which back then was a part of
russian empire but obviously the word
ukraine is never mentioned in the film
here's how they show ukrainians
[Music]
and of course russians depict ukrainians
in the most stereotypic way remember how
in previous films ukrainians were always
drinking eating pickler and borscht well
it's the same here
again russian creators don't shy away
from mocking the ukrainian language
characters who are chosen to represent
locals are heard speaking very broken
almost comical version of ukrainians
[Music]
there's also a scene featuring a
ukrainian wedding
however again elements of ukrainian
culture are shown in the russian
environment we never learned from the
film that this is ukrainians and ukraine
that are being portrayed on the screen
in fact for someone who is not from this
region it might appear that ukrainians
in the past were in fact russian because
we never see them as self-defined at
least not in this film the next film is
called the union of salvation it is a
2019 russian war epic period adventure
film directed by andrei kravchuk this
film is about the group of anti-star
conspirators who became known as
decemberists to revolt in the film
russian generals and soldiers refer to
kiev a lot however for some reason it's
located in a fictional country called by
russians molorosia or little russia
yeah
at the same time their location caption
says ukraine cave province this might be
an intentional move to actually show
that ukraine has always been a part of
historic great russia and again there is
a stereotype about piglar being used
conveniently in the story just look what
they ask the general who's being sent to
ukraine
the entire film provides a clear russian
perspective on ukraine that didn't
change much from desire russia
ukrainians are portrayed as little
russians and ukraine is often referred
to as malorosia or little russia that
makes the audience believe that it
doesn't have any particular culture
except of drinking and eating piglet
moving on to the next film chernobyl
abyss that was released in 2021 this is
a russian film directed by daniela
kozlowski in a response to a famous hbo
series chernobyl russians didn't really
like how they were portrayed in the film
and the leaders and authorities so they
decided to create their own disaster
drama this film represents or rather
misrepresents a story that fully
develops in ukraine in 1986
just four years before ukraine voted to
become an independent country from
soviet union but this film makes people
believe that ukraine as a country
emerged outside of some sort of vacuum
because in this film we see
the country the republic portrayed as a
part of the ussr however we never see
ukrainians or ukrainian culture
mentioned in the film this is a
particular convenient narrative for a
country whose leader justifying the
invasion of ukraine with some
quasi-historic narratives the next film
in this sequence are supposed to
represent post-maidan ukraine the
russian character this film shows a
russian coming to crimean being shocked
at how nationalistic and ukrainian it is
the inhabitants are shown speaking
primarily ukrainian but this is not an
act of mercy from the russian directors
whose colleagues were mocking the
ukrainian language for years ukrainian
language in crimea is shown to scare the
russians about what could have happened
with the peninsula had russia not saved
it
foreign
the russian protagonist constantly meets
pathetic and mean ukrainians on his
journey
[Music]
another film called crimea was released
in 2014 as a story of love faith honor
against the backdrop of the real events
of the crimean spring of 2014 or that's
how the film is being described on imbd
in reality it was a masterful piece of
propaganda in lies the film opens with a
sequence of a protagonist laughing at
the girl for coming to write about
ukrainian history to crimea implying
that it's something absolutely
impossible because there is no ukrainian
history in crimea according to russia
on the seventh minute of the film they
start showing the scenes from maidan of
revolution which was an uprising by
ukrainian people against their
pro-russian government at that time but
for russians of course it's some sort of
staged coup by the americans the
protagonist stands on the side of the
policemen who are being unfairly
attacked by the protesters he gets
closer to one of them and he explains
how the entire protest has been
orchestrated
the movie actually shows how regular
crimeans are being beaten up by some
crazy far-right extremists in ukraine
this is based on zero factual evidence
but who cares right
the film fully backs up russian
conspiracy theory that tells that
ukrainian maidan revolution was
organized and planned to repress
everyone in ukraine and force them to be
ukrainian then the plot focus shifts
from the personal story of the
protagonist to the annexation or how the
russians would like to say liberation of
crimea we see another very popular
russian narrative in this film victim
blaming russians blame other countries
and people for defending themselves they
say that if they were to lay down their
arms they wouldn't be dying
in the end the film shows the ukrainians
that matures who actually wanted to
stand up and fight russians when those
were taking over crimea
but russians quickly found them and
prevented from the bloodshed the film
ends with a tribute to the russians and
ukrainian military officers who did not
shoot each other in march of 2014. it is
written in a way to make you think that
russia is actually against spilling
blood unfortunately we know it's not
true this was the last film on our list
as we told you at the beginning this
video is an ambitious effort to show you
how ukrainians have been portrayed in
the russian cinema throughout history
the role of the visual media in the
formation of societal values cannot be
overstated we've seen how the russian
cinema uses colonial narratives to
belittle ukrainians mock their culture
and demonstrate the russian superiority
over ukraine it plays directly hand in
hand with the kremlin propaganda and its
efforts to erase ukraine and its culture
as such this kind of portrayal of
ukrainians and cinema makes you
understand why so many russians actually
support the current invasion of ukraine
for years they've been told that they
are superior over ukrainians that their
culture is greater and ukraine actually
doesn't have any historic grounds to
exist these kinds of narratives have
been constantly repeated on russian tvs
whether it's in the speeches of their
president or in their cinema and it
manifests in one kind of emotion hatred
towards ukrainians that can justify
their death and suffering